[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
the new demand from the prosecutor of
the so-called doomsday cult couple
what evidence is now being sought in the
lorry vallo and chad day bell case
prosecutors seek the death penalty for a
suspect indicted in the murder of a
woman
and the presumed murder of her little
boy they're still looking for nylo
but it's pretty clear that
he died a miserable death the florida
sheriff taking matters into his own
hands
in the arrest of an accused animal
abuser if you harm an animal in brevard
county
i'm personally going to walk you into
our jail and slam the door in your face
plus the woman sharing her story of
alleged sexual assault at a troubled
teen ranch
no child should suffer abuse and no
child should ever be sent to these
ranches
why she says she was inspired by paris
hilton law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to long crime daily i'm
brian buckmeyer along with terry austin
the prosecutor of the so-called doomsday
cult couple is turning up the heat
rob wood has filed his own motion to
compel asking a judge to make defense
attorneys
hand over a survey for why they say a
change of venue is warranted
lori valo and her husband chad dabell
are charged with concealing and
destroying evidence
while valo's children were reported
missing authorities discovered the
bodies of jj and tyler ryan
buried in shallow graves on daybell's
property the defense wants to move their
trial to another county
saying they won't be able to get an
impartial jury in fremont county
now prosecutor wood is demanding they
hand over a survey
that day bell's attorney says he plans
to enter
into evidence the defense reportedly had
a survey or poll
conducted as proof for why the change of
venue is needed
a hearing on the matter is scheduled for
march 10th in the meantime
abc's 2020 is airing a special on the
case
this friday
they were actively preparing for the end
so she planned on surviving the end of
the world
yes this is the story
chad lori you tell me where your kids
are tell us where your kids are
everybody wants to know
that's stunned a nation how does a
mother
who loved her children do a 180
like that it's very bizarre
now to ohio where a man can be put to
death for the murders of his
ex-girlfriend
and her three-year-old son law and
crimes angenette levy is here to tell us
about the new indictment
and how the little boy is still missing
yeah that's right brian you know we've
been telling you about nylo lattimore
and
his mom since last december nilo is
still
missing but cincinnati police and
prosecutors say he is dead
and that desean brown is responsible
it's a gruesome case i cannot even
imagine
what that little boy was going through
more than two months after nylo
lattimore's mother naitisha was killed
and he went missing
the prosecutor announced deshawn brown
will face the possibility of the death
penalty for their murders
he knew what he wanted to do for you
know a couple months and went
and did it carried it out ordered a body
bag
prosecutor joe deters says desean brown
killed nytesha lattimore in her
apartment on december 5th
deters says these surveillance photos
show brown carrying nyetisha's body out
of her apartment building
six days later in the body bag deters
says brown took an uber to the ohio
river
telling the driver the large item he was
carrying was closed
hours later on december 12 a security
guard found the body bag near a bridge
by that point deters says nylo had
already been killed
he didn't want nilo's existence traced
back to him after he killed nylo's
mother
so he made a choice deters says brown
threw nilo into the ohio river alive
the day after he killed his mother
nilo's stroller was found in the river
the day after naitisha's body was found
questions have been raised about filing
a murder charge without
a body you can prove cases without a
body
deters points to the murder of cary
culberson in 1996.
her body has never been found but her
ex-boyfriend was convicted of killing
her
meanwhile volunteers have spent
countless hours searching the ohio river
and its banks for nilo's body it's been
countless hours that they've searched
for this baby and and it will continue
until we we do ultimately find him
desean brown had already pleaded not
guilty to
tisha latimore's murder but he'll be
arraigned again
on these new charges next week i
contacted his lawyer seeking a comment
and so far
he has not called me back brian terry
the way i understand it the death
penalty is on the table
because of the death of nilo or the fact
that two or more people were murdered
do you think the prosecution will have
trouble getting the death penalty with
only half of the victims though
you know brian i think it's possible
they could get the death penalty
i mean they do have the body of the
mother and that might just be enough
you know ohio is only one of 28 states
that
actually has the death penalty having
said that
governor mike dewine has already
indefinitely
suspended all capital punishments it's
his view
that the lethal injection is not a good
way to do
the death penalty and he also thinks
that the time between the conviction
and the actual you know capital
punishment
is too long and it's not a deterrent so
we'll see if it actually happens here
now dina in a few moments once he gets
arraigned on the new charges
we will have a double homicide the
homicide of nilo though will almost
completely be circumstantial
what arguments could a defense attorney
make to avoid that guilty verdict
i mean a case against brown is very
strong but they're gonna be able to
create some sort of doubt the fact that
there is not a body
but we see convictions all the time when
there isn't a body
and and that makes sense we don't want
somebody who does commit murder just
because they hide a body well to be able
to
get off on the murder and there is
evidence such as the fact that there's
the child's blood is on the blanket his
stroller is in the river
and the fact that a three-year-old is
not gonna go very far
so the fact that he has not been seen
for so long
although it's circumstantial it's a very
strong case and i think that
even if there's doubt there's not going
to be reasonable doubt here
yeah i'd agree too and jeannette the
prosecutor said brown planned the murder
of nitisha latimore for more than for
two months sorry
is that how they're pursuing the death
penalty
yeah brian that's only just a small part
of it that's because in ohio
premeditation
of a crime is not enough to seek the
death penalty there also have to be
these aggravating circumstances
the prosecutor said that the aggravating
circumstances in this case are the fact
that two or more people
were murdered and they say they know
that nilo is dead
even though his body hasn't been found
and the fact that nilo was younger than
13
is the other aggravating factor all
right we'll keep eyes on this case thank
you all for the update
still ahead on law and crime daily lady
gaga's dog walker
shot and her dog stolen the award she's
offering for information in the case
but first prosecutors wrap up their case
in the trial of a man charged with
murdering his wife
and making her body disappear will the
jury believe it our legal analysis
next
[Music]
welcome back the state has rested in the
no body murder trial of a man accused of
killing his wife
in wisconsin james procopovich is
charged with first-degree intentional
homicide
of victoria procopovich she's been
missing since 2013
and her body has never been found
investigators say it was part of the
defendant's plan
to be with his new girlfriend catherine
friday friday the defendant were charged
with lying about when they met
but friday died before her sentencing in
2016 the defendant spoke with a private
investigator
hired by the victim's family who accused
him of killing his wife
yeah i know you know but say god forbid
something would happen to your wife
you'd be able to tell everybody what she
had on
or what she wore if you guys think i
need something
damn it arrest me and hold me in because
i didn't
i he said i did
at that interview right to me
i know you did something to that woman
i'm talking about it well
that's why well because sometimes you
get angry like this i don't feel safe
so i asked i don't get angry very often
but this is getting to be what's
ridiculous i just ask you
we're trying to help you i know you're
trying to
remember but three and a half years
don't
tell me you don't remember i don't
remember i'll move on to the next day
where i was sitting when
down but you remember there was here
that was here
prosecutors contend that the defendant
disposed of the victim's body in a
sludge pond
but the defense asked the lead
investigator if he ever found evidence
of that want to be clear that it had
nothing to do with the cold
i personally remember drilling holes in
the ice and diving underneath them to
look for victoria prokapovics
we also were hopeful that
primarily because of statements made by
mr prokopowitz that during hunting
season there will be more
eyes and boots on the ground
and um at least up through november of
2013
so far your efforts didn't better out
any information of the whereabouts of
victoria
pocapo it's true correct no information
relating to her whereabouts
here to break down the no body murder
trial in wisconsin is legal analyst dina
dahl and terry austin
terry based on your impression of this
witness so far
do you think the investigator helped the
prosecution establish their case
i do i think this was a very strong
witness for the prosecution he was able
to establish the fact
that they had done exhaustive searches
you heard him there talk about going
under the water he also was able to
establish that
the defendant wasn't at all interested
in helping the authorities
and he basically said he was
cold-hearted he was controlling he was
lying and even
abusive the real question here brian is
whether or not all of that is enough to
return a guilty verdict
because frankly at the end of the day
just because he's
not a nice person doesn't mean he killed
his wife exactly
dina the defendant james prokopovic is
not testifying but i'm calling it now i
think it's going to be a hung jury
you've been following most of this case
what do you think
you know i said that yesterday because i
think people have very strong opinions
about this case so i either could see
that or conviction
you know there's a lot of facts against
him the domestic violence
repeatedly lying to authorities you know
his
obsession with this woman that he has an
affair with shortly after
the only reasonable doubt that the
defense is creating is this is that
maybe she killed herself because of her
history with depression
but there's zero evidence of her leaving
her home no evidence of her footsteps or
anything
so to me this case seems very much the
prosecution's favor
but different people will think
differently about the idea of
you know the depression um angle that
the defense is bringing up
and she did say and i think it did come
out that if she did commit suicide
they'd never find her body
it's doubt the question is is it
reasonable thank you both
coming up on law on crime daily how
investigators believe hackers attempted
to break into a water treatment plant's
computer system plus the sheriff's
slamming jail doors on a suspect
charged with starving two dogs to death
his personal message to the defendant
next
[Music]
we're back a florida sheriff is sending
a strong message to animal abusers that
he will personally walk them into jail
not only is this person responsible for
the death of two innocent animals
he literally starved them to death over
a period of several weeks
after the dogs were found dead and
necropsy revealed chips of wood from
furniture
plastic bottles band-aids even a plastic
bag in the stomach of these poor
innocent dogs
these poor animals were literally eating
furniture and their own feces trying
desperately to stay alive
so david fritsch this is what you wanted
you wanted to go to jail apparently
you couldn't take the responsibility to
take care of an animal so
i'm going to walk you into jail i guess
you didn't get the memo about don't hurt
animals
you don't have old facts no i believe i
do have the facts there's two dogs dead
that you were responsible for
yeah so you don't understand the
situation well
i don't need to our investigators did a
great job putting you behind bars
like i said don't hurt an animal in
brevard county
lady gaga is offering a 500 thousand
dollar reward
for information leading to the return of
her two pooches after her dog walker was
shot
police in los angeles say the victim was
walking the dogs
at 9 40 p.m wednesday night the suspects
shot him and stole the two french
bulldogs koji and gustav
her third dog reportedly was able to get
away the lapd says the shooters used a
semi-automatic gun
and fled the scene in a white vehicle
according to tmz her
dog walker ryan fisher is recovering
from his injuries
a florida water treatment plant was
unsuccessfully targeted by hackers
the fbi is now saying the plan had
outdated computer software
chief investigative correspondent brian
ross looks into what the hackers might
have been after
thanks brian coming up this week on
brian ross investigates
troubling questions about the safety and
the security of our water and power
supply we all saw what happened in texas
but also troubling a development in
florida where officials discovered
somebody hacked into the water district
computers and tried
to poison the water the hacker changed
the sodium hydroxide
from about 100 parts per million to 11
100 parts per million this is obviously
a significant and potentially dangerous
increase
sodium hydroxide also known as lye is
the main ingredient
in liquid drain cleaners chlorine gas
you might recall from history
is what was used in world war one by the
germans and the british
to kill each other it was a chemical
weapon
and so if somehow you can get into
the controls of a local water system
and open the valves uh of the chlorine
gas
and let that cloud float out into the
community
uh you have a lethal situation that's
coming up
this week on brian ross investigates on
the long crime trial network back to you
brian
thanks brian when we come back a young
woman's warning about the troubled teen
industry
her calls for reform inspired by paris
hilton velocity you need to hear
after the break
welcome back a young woman is coming
forward with sexual assault allegations
she says
she experienced at a teen rehab center
associated with the dr phil show
and says a celebrity inspired her to do
so
paris hilton testified in front of the
utah senate just weeks ago
about her personal allegations of abuse
at a troubled teen camp
hilton is advocating for more regulation
in the industry
hannah archuleta says the testimony
inspired her to report abuse at another
camp
when she was 17 years old archuleta says
she was carted away
to turnabout ranch in utah in 2019
after appearing on the dr phil show she
claims a male staffer assaulted her
twice
and others threatened her if she spoke
up
i had recently learned that my mother
was formerly ill with liver failure
and heartbroken at the ranch
i was alone and isolated from all of my
family
within the first two weeks at turnabout
ranch a male staff member came
up behind me and suddenly grabbed my
butt
i decided not to tell anyone because i
was scared
of being punished and i hoped that he
would not touch me again
sadly i was wrong later
while i was reaching up into a cabinet
the same male staff
grabbed my butt and touched my vaginal
area i was
required to spend extra time picking up
horse manure
walking in circles around a horse corral
and sitting at a desk facing a wall for
hours
i had to do forced labor outside and
below freezing temperatures
and sleep on a wooden plank with no
pillow
in addition the retaliation included
refusing the access to the bathroom
and denigrating and humiliating me in
front of others
when i was finally able to contact my
parents and tell them what happened
my parents rescued me from the program
on december 19th
hannah's father said he tried to report
the abuse to local law enforcement
but was ignored
i spoke with a woman who had provided me
with a case number
and she said the original investigating
officer was no longer employed there
and that he passed the case down to his
son who was
also a garfield county deputy
i then left a message to please contact
me
but after that i was never contacted by
anyone from garterfield county sheriff's
office by phone
or writing directly or indirectly i
personally
feel they swept this under the rug
without even bothering to interview
hannah as a victim
famed woman's rights attorney gloria
allred is representing archuleta
in her lawsuit they support paris
hilton's call for reform
to make matters worse the male staff
member that she accused
was permitted to remain on the job and
the lawsuit alleges that females
who were minors at the school were not
warned about him
and the danger that hannah believed that
he presented
our lawsuit also alleges that the ranch
failed to
inform law enforcement officials that
hannah
a 17 year old minor had reported that
she had been assaulted by a male staff
member
we think it is long overdue for
turnabout ranch
to be held accountable for what happened
to hannah
when she was there for this reason
we filed her lawsuit today alleging
negligent hiring and supervision
assault battery and intentional
infliction of emotional distress
we are seeking compensatory and punitive
damages
according to proof at trial
here to discuss allegations of sexual
assault on the turnabout ranch
is terry austin and dina dahl some
describe it as a wilderness therapy and
residential treatment center but
to this woman who's accusing the staff
member of sexually assaulting her not
once
but twice and then the ranch supposedly
sweeping it on the rug
this could be a long road to justice
dina what should we expect in this case
now that the lawsuit has been filed you
know
two main points this is a negligence
civil case not a criminal case so
the standard of proof that she needs to
prove here
is not beyond a reasonable doubt it is
preponderance of the evidence
so it is a lesser standard and easier
for her to prove than if she were in
court
it'll be more difficult because you know
here she had gloria allred a lot of
people in this situation may not have a
lawyer and depend on the criminal
justice system
the second point is that the defense the
first thing they're going to want to do
is get the intentional affliction
emotional distress
dismissed because that comes with the
punitive damages
and that's something that they're going
to want to avoid so those are things to
look out for in this case
now terry if true who's on the hook for
this sexual assault the staff member his
supervisor
the whole camp the list goes on right
exactly conceptually everyone could be
on the hook you heard gloria allred
they're talking about the fact that it's
negligent hiring negligent
supervision so clearly the individual
who actually committed the offense
is on the hook but the supervisor the
whole school
and even if i should you know look at
this and look at it in totality
the police because you heard the father
there say that it was reported to the
police as well so
i think they all are on the hook all
right dina and terry thank you very much
and thank you for joining us here on law
on crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you